europe needs to be united as one power
so in 25 years in 2015 we will all live
in a strong eu in a peaceful world
a timely recommendation at the plenary
of the conference on the future of
europe where representatives of european
citizens panels championed their ideas
for tomorrow's eu
foreign affairs were sent a stage in
strasbourg as the conference plenary
heard from ukrainian lawmakers
ngo members and citizens invited to
speak about the war in their homeland
right now as i speak
ukrainians are fighting for our european
values
today i'm asking you for your support in
our common struggle
the eu's place in the world was among
the issues brought into sharper focus as
panel representatives debated 88
recommendations with members of european
and national parliaments eu institutions
trade unions and stakeholders other
topics include jobs social justice and
how to foster a stronger more ethical
economy
we want stricter rules
for the import of products into the eu
for example
we want all producers to comply to human
rights and to be devoid of child labour
citizens also put forward their ideas on
youth and culture the digital
transformation and the rules governing
eu borders
panel fear and field writing
plenary is set to turn the panel's
recommendations into concrete proposals
the conclusions of this conference will
need to reflect
the ongoing tragedy in ukraine
it is clear
the future will be different
from what we could imagine
only even a few weeks ago